what is going on there citizens of the rejack
nation we just got out of watching Indiana
Jones and the dial of Destiny and I just
got out of I mean like 15 minutes ago we
saw it at a theater nearby once we found a
reasonably quiet spot to set up and film it
there were literally popo right around I was like
I'm dealing with this Burbank today especially for
this movie we're just gonna go to my backyard
still do it standing so it feels a little bit
more like we just got out of the theater so ladies
and Gentlemen please go ahead Fred's a friend's
friend hey Whip that like button before we go into
our review for this let's give you guys a little
plot synopsis of what this movie's all about all
right so Indy is old he's like really old but
he's got his trademark for Dora and his whip at
the ready because he's on a mission to retrieve
a powerful artifact that could shake the very
foundations of history but he's not alone on this
Quest joined by his goddaughter Indy's got more
than just ancient booby traps and deadly foes to
contend with he's got to keep up with a whip smart
young companion who's just as eager to uncover the
secrets of the past and speaking of foes watch
out for Jurgen Vala this former Nazi might work
for NASA now but he's still up to his old Nazi
tricks you Nazis and he'll stop at nothing to
get his hands on the dial of Destiny it's a Race
Against Time as Indian as goddaughter they never
these treacherous ruins sort of and outwit their
enemies sort of will they retrieve the dial of
Destiny before it's too late did it warn unless
the mediocre five minutes Standing Ovation at
Cannes Film Festival we're here to tell you right
now if it does we only talked about it during the
credits we didn't ride together to the theater
I was thinking about how we could structure this
to convey our appearances if we're mainly on the
same page but there's one thing we're not really
on the same page about I feel like the best way
to go about it is to go through it act by Act of
the emotional experience we were feeling through
it John do you remember in Indiana Jones Raiders
of the Lost Ark when he switches out the bag and
the the artifact the bag I think he has a he has a
mixed bag in there oh yeah okay one's the prologue
that out it seems like everyone's Keen to spoil
for you guys so I'm gonna do it right now too it
starts off in the 1940s setting up everything to
come you got this young Indiana Jones and then you
see how they get their hands on half of the dial
of Destiny how it's being kept by the Nazis led
by mads Mickelson Indiana Jones has teamed up with
physical Wilder Bridge's dad played by Toby Jones
it's a prologue that's supposed to feel like the
old Indiana Jones movies John you have way more
of a nostalgic love for Indiana Jones than I do
what did you think about that prologue I thought
the prologue was decent kind of went halfway for
me I mean the first thing you notice obviously is
the de-aging technology on Harrison Ford which at
times looks pretty amazing and at other times has
all the pitfalls that we've come to expect from
that particular effect but that aside yeah it's a
fun you know clippy adventurous prologue it sets
everything up it you know is indicative I think
of the pace the rest of the movie kind of has it
moves it's sort of a Breakneck kind of speed but
there is a lot of fun there there's a good sort
of imagination and a nice contained wrap around
to it all before the main Venture sets off yeah
it's like crazy [__] that Indiana is pulling
off yes in this adventure right Beyond just the
de-aging which did have this emotional journey
of wow that looks great to oh I don't know about
that too sometimes same shot being like whoa that
looks real wait his mouth is moving that looks off
that looks really off and his voice sounds just as
old as he doesn't know Annunciation ain't matching
it this looks great when you're not showing him
talk I like it when he's not talking yeah it was
never quite immersive because it was constantly
fluctuating between it and I feel like a general
audience member of what he experiences I'm not
just talking about people with that critical lie
I did enjoy it I thought it ended up being like
a lot of fun it felt a little bit like they were
trying to capture the spirit instead of genuinely
being the spirit there but for the most part you
know I'd be lying if I said I didn't actually
enjoy it but then I started to love the movie
because then we really kick off act one where you
step from like the fantasy of Indiana Jones into
harsh old man reality of Indiana Jones and the
washed up old guy the first shot of Harrison
Ford of today minor spoiler very vulnerable he
is shirtless out of shape cranky hung over he's
in a terrible mood on the day of his retirement
which also happens to be Moon day the day the
Americans reached the moon all by ourselves with
no help from anyone from elsewhere in the world
I imagine maybe some people might react to it
with the oh my God are they Luke skywalkering
this are they Last Jedi or Indiana Jones throw
the whip over his shoulder into stain I think
it works better here because of the fact that
Indiana Jones is just a human and being and I
loved the portrayal here because they were setting
up some really interesting things I can't spoil
for you guys because there were some personal
life struggles that he's going through here
that raised a question mark of stuff like what's
going on with the Indiana Jones's son what's going
on with Karen Allen they do acknowledge that it
really is intertwined with what Indiana Jones is
dealing with so I don't want to give it away
but I loved what they set up and I loved the
way it was all playing out I loved the Aesthetics
the production design the whole vibe and Aura in
the mood and that's when you meet Phoebe Waller
Bridge's character Helena who is his goddaughter
and you see this instant chemistry where there's
this twinkle back in Harrison Ford's eye feeling
good about the past and then she wants to find
the other half of the dial of Destiny for a lot
of her own reasons right and then it leads into
this eventual people of course you know you got
like mads Mickelson you got Boyd Holbrook they're
all like chasing after the same thing so they're
chasing after her that's where you see all that
stuff in the trailer with the big parade and
Indie on the horse and the train like the main
good stuff I loved it I mean did you love I I
see yeah like all of that like the whole like that
whole like 20 minute chunk that tension at Stakes
it had a rousing spirit to it I loved all of it I
was like I don't know what all these critics are
talking about yeah this movie's a blast absolutely
and it's cool to see him in the 60s in a slightly
different context and setting you know in the
city all that stuff and then and then you gotta
get Indiana Jones overseas across the world slowly
but surely everything about the movie started to
not work for me it started feeling rote monotonous
perfunctory like the pacing started feeling dull
everything started feeling forced it started
feeling like James Mangold was at a Crossroads
between the kind of movies he wanted to make
because in the beginning of it it seemed like oh
he's kind of doing a bit of like a Logan approach
but not like as heavy or harrowing but with the
Indiana Jones backdrop you know and I thought
that was great because it was really clicky like
all the tone phones were just it was perfect like
what a great sequel setup the legacy sequel great
job and then here it's like they set up all these
things with Indiana Jones being this like elderly
guy who's like been out of the game and all these
things and then when he gets back overseas it's
just kind of like we're supposed to forget about
all that and he's just moving along no problem
and then more importantly this is the pacing of
it just became so boring how would you describe
the I think we joked about it in the middle of
the movie of what the basic structure was well
yeah it's like Indiana Jones will arrive at a
place he'll have an argument usually with Phoebe
Waller Bridge or somebody they'll establish like
the next destination or the next McGuffin they
gotta go get and then oh man's Mickelson shows
up and now we gotta have a fight and now we gotta
move on to the next place and you'll forget about
mads Mickelson for a while while they repeat that
cycle and then he'll show up again to be one
step behind everything in the recycle repeat
everything just started feeling like it was trying
to be Indiana Jones the old movies instead of just
being its own thing which surprised me because
I'm like James mangle come on man Just Do Your
Own Thing through your dreams you usually do
Your Own Thing saying why am why is this the
least I have felt your voice in a movie and you've
done franchise movies too and yeah I mean with the
mcguffins it just becomes on now they got it
and now we got it now they got it now we got
it and there's not really much of like a visual
flavor or a dynamic to the pacing it's always the
characters yeah it moves in kind of a mono type of
pace that is just chop chop chop and it feels very
much a victim of you know the modern Blockbuster
sensibility where I feel like it really could have
benefited from some of the breathing room and the
tangibility that the original movies it is trying
to emulate had it takes you across the world to
all these exotic locations but you don't really
feel like you're spending much time there and
even the tombs and the puzzles and stuff like
that are like pretty brief I would find myself
getting into a moment being like yeah now this
is Indiana oh oh we're moving on okay here's what
I'll say I think Harrison Ford is excellent here
it's easy easily there's no question about it
he's doing great work it's his most emotional
performance of the Indiana Jones films he really
cares he's not just showing up and pretending to
be and yet Joe it's like he really cares and
shows in this film shows in the interviews and
the press that he does for it specifically this
portrayal they have some emotional moments here
that I thought they really could have played into
like there's a line in the trailer where Harrison
Ford he's saying it's not about what you believe
it's about how hard you believe so you kind of
think that that's what this movie is going to be
about but no it's not uh like they have a scene
where they say it but it's not really demonstrated
yeah and nor does that matter in this movie and I
mean the particular plot that they're going after
isn't something he is especially passionate about
as a character exactly and that actually undercuts
a lot of the fun of the journey because Harrison
Ford himself his whole purpose of going on this is
I'm just trying to clear my name for not getting
blamed for [__] that happened because I'm
the tiger I just want to sleep in my apartment
enjoy my retirement like he has no real vested
interest in this to like I need to the trailers
try to trick you into thinking I've been looking
for this all my life this is the journey I never
gotta finish and now I'm going to finish it the
trailers are trying to tell you that but that's
not what's Happening Here the movie tries to trick
you to think it's like doing this it's going to
Crescendo into this theme of something but nah
no no you get the crescendo moment without the
entire movie that ought to have proceeded it to
really sell what the emotions of that real climax
ought to be Phoebe Waller Bridge that's what I
feel like you and I are kind of on a disagreement
here because I am 100 sexist and I agree with the
entire sex inside of the internet about oh my God
and I want her to be Indiana Jones yeah that's
what I was hoping for and we got it it's not as
cut and dry as that I don't want a song I don't
like her I started off with oh she's Charming too
I don't like the way you're reading you're kind of
annoying to eventually within like the last like
40 to 45 minutes of this I really started to like
her a lot and I feel like she and Harrison Ford
have easily some of the best scenes in this movie
for sure close to the end of this film by the end
of it I really liked her a lot yeah I like the two
of them together I thought the emotion of that and
just what they were at least alluding to even if
it wasn't always in the dialogue and whatever just
the aura of their shared relationship was really
lovely and I liked her you know like knowledgeable
but feisty kind of persona I feel like even though
people love to complain about that these days it's
well at home in a world like this and you can
see how she's reigniting that spark for him I
like that a lot and even her you know having her
own little short round guy kind of made for a
nice just interesting beat for that character even
if that was nowhere near as engaging or you know
lovable as actual Short Round yeah it was kind
of okay it's more like hey remember Short Round
We got up we had a much more restrained version
here we got a lot more restrained versions of
everything you remember and that's the the thing
is everyone's comparing this to Crystal Skull and
I'm like in some ways Crystal Skull has more like
flavor and takes more swings and in some ways this
one is much more sort of akin to what you want but
really they both kind of balance out to me by the
end of the day I would actually I would meet you
on that then you got mads Mickelson here who is
yes a ruthless cunning scientist Nazi guy who was
going forward this more real like Menace gravitas
portrayal like you see mads Mickelson do in movies
yeah like you wanted him to go bigger which feels
like the plot could have warranted it for sure
yeah that he's got going on here yeah yeah and
his obsession I just feel like you know given that
it's Indiana Jones I don't mind a different take
on a villain but you know I mean escalated into
madness that's part of what we do here yeah yeah
I I can I can see where you're coming from because
again a lot of this came down to its energy and
it's feeling like they were trying to capture the
spirit but it was dragging I think where James
Mangold and Company I don't really know where this
movie movie went wrong for it because clearly like
it went around for a lot of people where I thought
they were trying to be a little bit deceitful here
a little manipulative like they had this crazy
cool action scene in their first overseas car
chase that you see a lot of and the trailers and
I like the car sure it was it was cool I didn't
feel any like tension or any but I know something
was off and I was like this doesn't feel genuinely
exciting this just feels like I'm watching some
cool shots here and there but I don't find this
exciting it's not as tangible like I think
India Indiana Jones especially I think doesn't
work well swing monkey Vines just level but yeah
no but even that I'll forgive because I'm like
well you need CG for that I guess but yeah they
relied too heavily on CG in these recent Indiana
Jones is where the previous ones would have had
to have made sure a lot of it practically and
then resorted to visual effects yeah then any
following action scenes I don't even remember
what really happened honestly yeah they all just
started blending together and they don't really
distinguish themselves too much so if you're able
to have fun with this movie like a lot of people
who've been able to come out of this film going I
don't care what critics because I thought I was I
thought I was becoming that guy like I wanted to
be in the first like 30 minutes I was like oh my
God yeah I'm bad guy then as they're wet I was
like no this is this is tough this is this is
really boring this is a really boring film because
I'm bringing up all the characters due to the fact
that this movie set up so many things that it's
not just Greg having like wish like fulfillment
needs it's with the movie set up and I thought
okay they've sent us some interesting things
here mads Mickelson The prologue like wow what a
great way to to make him more than just another
Nazi this guy should have a very personal Vendetta
especially after what happens to this guy no uh it
doesn't even seem like it's brought up ever in
the conversations with Phoebe Waller bridge in
him it just felt like banter and not anything
with real depth until close to the end of this
film it feels like there were two drafts of this
that were very much at War and they're like four
credited writers it feels like one of them was
just the adventure and just the plot beats and
stuff and then there was a different version
where it's like let's do the send-off ride into
the sunset you know embracing your age story and I
really feel like they kept one or two three Beats
from that personal story and then mostly went
with the big action Blockbuster which is fine
but these movies are capable of doing both I know
people argue you don't come to Indiana Jones for a
drama or a character study but with the amount of
love the series has garnered and the way it's tied
to Harrison Ford and with movies like Maverick or
even the John Wicks in acknowledging the age of
their stars and letting them kind of break that
fourth wall they really missed an opportunity to
do that here like Harrison Ford's portrayal of
his Walk of Life at this point is Indiana Jones
is lovely when you get to Glimpse it but they
don't spend much time on that however in the
finale and maybe some of you guys have heard this
this is when the movie decides to try something
different I like the different thing they did
I thought there was a cool mood and aura about
it there were some great visuals to it there's
some emotional heft and I really love the final
scene of this movie it's a great wraparound for
this specific journey of what Indiana is going
through in his personal life and the adventure
he just went on it's got great Nostalgia beats
to it in a way that felt like I actually had to
remind myself like people started like chuckling
at least certain things that were happening and
I and I I I like I said I'm not like massively
in love with the films so I had to like check
myself and go like what's oh yes that's what
that's what it is yeah yeah the Callback right
yeah yeah but that being said I thought it was
still working really well for me even without
immediately recognizing what the Callback was
in the finale it doesn't necessarily redeem
the The Experience though while I can isolate
and go I like that show it's a swing at least
it was cool it was cool it doesn't ultimately
redeem the experience that it left me with for
the mo for most of this film which was this is
disappointing I cannot underscore the word trying
even more than I can now it is yeah you just feel
the word trying so it's busy and dense without
being rich yeah overall for me I would be like a
52 on this movie honestly like I cannot I cannot
say that over like that 50 that percent that I'm
recommend is like all in the first half hour where
I loved it and then the the finale parts were like
yeah it was nice yeah sure sure I mean yeah on a
generous day I might go to like 60 but really it
is in that 50 range because I think some people
as demonstrated with a lot of the responses some
people gonna love it some people are gonna feel
like us and at the end of it I just wasn't really
moved a lot by much so what is your favorite
Indiana Jones movie leave your thoughts down below
um you can subscribe leave a like uh did you
like this one we will talk with you all soon um